this guy has all the answers he went to
Duke he knows all the answers to all the
tests you never cheated off anybody's
paper did you Seth Davis I'm sorry I got
a bad you was this that presupposes that
I went to class okay
so you have to be in the class to cheat
off is it hard is it harder to just get
into Duke than it is to stay at Duke
well it's impossible now I mean the Seth
Davis of 1988 would have no chance to
get him to Duke really know my my sons
are screwed Dejan in that respect and so
they haven't given them any money so
that's not gonna help with that
affiliation so no III know this hard to
stay there so much as you know you meet
a lot of sort of you know type a high
achieving people that you circulate you
know your fraternity brothers your
classmates and obviously me being there
during the Christian Laettner era you
know I was there they went to four Final
Fours they played in three final games
and they won it twice so what was tough
at the college basketball what was
Laettner's reputation among fellow
students I'm sorry I got bad connection
here you want to get another question or
what I'm kidding I'm kidding
um later was Laettner I mean you know he
was certainly so it means everything I
mean you know he wasn't disarming I mean
I was in the same dorm with him I
freshman year I always liked him and I
still liked him
and I don't see him a whole lot but it
was like you know you were gonna kind of
engage with him on on his terms my
freshman year we were in the same dorm
and he would just stay all night
downstairs playing ping pong and just
crushing everybody a ping pong you can
imagine the wingspan and talking trash
about it so he was a lot of fun to be
around I mean he was definitely I mean
all those guys were very much you know
they were at parties you were a class
with them it's people don't realize how
small of a school Duke is about five six
thousand undergrads so everybody kind of
knows each other so and he was a very
good basketball player do you think he's
underrated no documentaries made about
him but but not about his greatness it's
about his personality it was more about
well when your documentary is I hate
Christian Laettner right it's it's it
feels like it's more his personality and
emotion that he brought out and I don't
think I do think Christian can be
likable I don't think it has ever
been all that important a Christian to
be likable I mean it's he's older now
you know and that arrogance that you
know he carries all the time certainly
helped him on the basketball court so
you know they're legions of stories
about you know how he was around his
teammates he went out of his way to be
mean to Bobby Hurley you know it was it
like he was toughening Bobby Hurley up
or was he just being Christian you know
I mean they're you know Grant Hill I
think was pretty nice too Bobby Hurley
and but that was his personal makeup and
he was all about winning later and she
chefs key loved him from the beginning I
mean those two had a karmic connection
Chesky understand he always said about
Laettner you know he's this he's his
burning flame he can heat your heat your
house or he can burn it down and so he
loved he loved that competitive spirit
so I mean Christians been out there I
think everybody everything that you
think about Christian is is is true I
mean I think his public persona is
pretty much the the Christian that I
know for better or worse and everything
in between
but you also have players it's gonna be
hard to replicate greatness from a team
perspective for a player because I don't
know if Laettner would have stayed all
four years correct these kids aren't
staying for years so when you're trying
to put them into a category it's it's
almost like you have just separated a
decade by decade yes I mean nobody's
gonna sue for everything right I mean
it's like how do you compare Tiger
versus Jack well the tiger have more you
know competition I think I think you're
absolutely correct you need to evaluate
in each era I think the watershed moment
for that was Kevin Garnett 1995 went
straight from high schools I think he
was the fifth pick in the draft and he'd
been the first high school player to do
that and I remember being at Sports
Illustrated the time and saying we
should do I remember interviewing then
like the top 20 kids in high school one
of whom was Kobe Bryant I called him at
his house and I said does what Kevin
Garnett did make you more inclined to
try to go straight to the NBA or leave
college early or maybe only stay one or
two years and I'll never forget his
answer he said I want to go to the NBA
as soon as possible because I don't want
Michael Jordan get too old I want to
play against him when he's when he's
young enough and for some reason that
that that stuck with me so yeah it's
it's it's a lot harder now it's a lot
hard to be that good I mean if you're
that good
you're not staying til your senior you
and Duke was really the last school the
lose guys Elton Brand you know left
after his sophomore year he was a number
one pick in the draft he was the first
guy really as an underclassmen to take
that route and obviously now they're all
even I was at a Cleveland sports banquet
so they had their yearly sports banquet
in Cleveland LeBron James is a senior in
high school a guy comes up to me he says
hey would you I hosted it and he said
would you talk to LeBron he's not sure
if he's going to go to college or he's
gonna go to go pro so you know now
you're thinking of course he's going pro
when he wasn't gonna go college but I
said have you reached out to Kobe and
have you reached out to Kevin Garnett
and I said and he said yes and I said
well there's your answer if they feel
like you're ready to go then go you know
now it's 15 years ago and you're going
up well it seems stupid that you would
even think that he would go 1 you
imagine if LeBron went to college for
one year it'd be pretty good and it
calls what's he wear was he was he
leaning towards any place you know like
Ohio State never got and it was so
obvious I remember being at ABCD camp in
New Jersey the summer before LeBron
junior year I had never heard of him
before I got there but by the time I got
there it was like the second day
everybody was talking about him I was
right there for the game when he crossed
over Lenny Cooke and Lenny Cooke fell
down cuz Lenny Cooke was the great
recruit out of New York but you know Dan
it's funny when people say like well
one-and-done is ruining college
basketball I try to remind people yeah
before one-and-done
there was none induction right but so
LeBron and Kobe all those guys went
straight to the league so was it better
for college basketball this season to
have Marvin Bagley and DeAndre Aten at
Duke in Arizona or with the Knicks and
the Lakers so I mean I'm personally in
favor of everybody doing whatever they
want to do I don't understand why it's a
problem if the Boston Celtics want to
draft a 13 year old 8th grader and pay
him a million dollars and develop him
and put them in the G League or whatever
why is that a problem for me I got three
kids of my own it's not good enough
problems you know so I don't understand
why it's such great consternation yeah
everybody does it we're talking about
what three to five kids a year I know
and everybody talks about on time so I'm
like everybody should be able to get
whatever they want
obviously there are plenty of examples
of people have gone straight from high
school in the league who have succeeded
and there are plenty of people who you
know who left early made bad decisions
stayed and stayed too long that College
made bad decisions everyone should be
entitled make their own mistakes could
Zion Williams can go right to the pros
now no question
no he's just physically ready I mean
he's like Dominique Wilkins not quite as
tall still developing his skillset if
anything he'd probably it would probably
benefit him to go to the pros now
because if you go to college you can't
get exposed so a lot of times it's about
striking the iron when the iron is hot
so every year there's maybe four or five
kids coming out of high school who could
legitimately benefit by going straight
to the NBA you know that's what they
with it and I'm with you on that because
I'd rather see you for one year than not
to get to see you at all and I know it
just feels like this is generational
it's somebody who's over 40 years of age
who has a problem with the one-and-done
you know that that you know what are you
doing to March Madness and you know
there's no continuity with basketball
and it's harder to follow and whereas
before you'd say boy I can't wait to see
that guy next year with the recruits
coming in you know in Kentucky is the
classic example imagine some of those
kids who were able to play with some of
the other kids being brought in I'm all
for free marketplace but you know Billis
talks about this in jail join us
tomorrow he's sort of saying open it up
highest bidder you want to bring in kids
and you want to pay them and you know
whatever you want to do I don't know if
we're ever gonna get there but
something's gonna happen soon it feels
like with college basketball in the NBA
well a couple things first of all in
terms of like March Madness is gonna be
fine
and look at March Madness the Final Four
we have here I think any of the four
teams we just ran a mock drafted at the
athletic yesterday they there's only two
kids at the Final Four in the first
round of that mock draft
Devonte Graham and McHale bridges of
Villeneuve not vogner not vybor DeWine
okay it's borderline Brunson is
borderline high mother Brunson is a pro
I think he got a good chance you know
like speed Makai looks got a very good
chance cuz the way she shoots it but all
of these guys had the option of turning
pro before and decline to do it because
it wasn't available to them so this idea
that if you get rid of one and done like
March Madness
college basketball is is very healthy
you know to Jays point Jay makes a lot
of very good points in terms of making
it more market sensible first of all
they have to build a new paradigm for
ages agents are to college basketball
which steroids have been to baseball
they're everywhere and so we need to
bring that out in the open and I think
this commission that emmert put together
the condi rice Commission they say
they're gonna come up with bold
proposals now their definition of bold a
narrow definition might be a little bit
different but I know they're gonna want
to open up the agents and maybe there's
you know professional affiliations like
they do in some of these other sports
baseball in particular and maybe even
financial transactions in the form of
legal loans now you're bringing taxes
and other regulations into it so there's
always gonna be a black market for this
stuff but I draw a very clear line at
this idea that you got to pay these guys
first of all we they already are getting
compensated quite well okay they get
tuition they get books they get food and
don't tell me that don't mean nothing I
mean I'm stressing saving for my kids
education don't tell me that an
education is not worth anything but if
you want to take the education out of it
and if they have aspirations to be a
professional how about their
professional training how about the kids
who are here at the Final Four what in
terms of coaching and training and game
experience and marketing and then I
laugh at this and I'm friends with these
guys Jay Williams and Jalen Rose oh the
players should boycott both those guys
played in the Final Four and neither of
them boycott it can you imagine working
your whole life and dreaming of playing
in the Final Four and summer
conditioning and fall workouts and all
this and sweating with your teammates
and your brothers and you win this and
cook like Kansas wins this incredible
game over Duke and now someone's gonna
get them together and say let's boycott
so we get more money I mean it's
ridiculous ethat money it's gonna be who
knows how many years down the road
before you know maybe another school or
these schools would get that so these
kids they want to play the phone your
old kid who just saw Pro 3-point shot of
his life by the way that was not a swish
that's what we now a bounce that's what
we now call that a sister Jean bounce
okay it pops around again really Grayson
Allen did not get the sister Jean oh yes
if Loyola wins the national title dot
dot dot dot dot dot unprecedented
incredible anything in college
basketball come close to them
I'm a little bit in the weeds on this
alright I'm a basketball nerd I wrote
about this today they are a really good
team they are a legitimately really good
team what they are doing in the
tournament is what they've done all
season long
they went thirty two and five three of
their losses came when their best player
Clayton Custer who was the Conference
Player of the Year was hurt so three of
the five with an injury they won their
league by four games they had a scare
early in the conference tournament but
they ended up winning the championship
game by 16 points they eviscerated a
pretty good Kansas State team that
finished fourth in the big 12 so this
idea that there's syndromic to me again
I'm a basketball nerd but obviously the
story first of all they be the lowest
seeded team ever to win the championship
you know the tie-in with the 1963 team
so it would be you know it's hard for me
to say unprecedented is it I don't know
if it's as unprecedent as when they
watch the biggest upset of all time and
it's not going over over Georgetown it's
not don't say that no because they
played twice during the internship game
upset
well Villanova is the lowest seeded team
to win the chance but if you saw those
games when they played the regular
season they were close very close games
this is what I'm talking about
we're talking about storylines and
narratives versus the truth NC State was
a that felt like a larger upset because
a hell great Houston want III would back
up and say you know what was the most
unlikely champion you know as opposed to
a championship game upset I mean how do
you even measure that is it by the point
spread I don't even know the answer to
that quite frankly I mean again I think
66 Texas Western might be kind of a
benchmark but you know back then we
maybe didn't realize how good these team
well they were at you know that was an
athletic team they had a great Co Hall
of Fame coach and Don Haskins right it's
just we didn't know about them there's a
difference of not knowing that's exactly
and we didn't know about Loyola unless
your nerd like I am who follows the
stuff all year I mean I've been watching
these guys all year listen they played
in December and they won at Florida true
road game in Gainesville one afar and at
the time we're like oh man Florida's it
like just has great wins like what's
wrong with Florida so you kind of paid
attention to these guys and they just
kept winning I'm a big believer that
winning is a habit what were you picking
villain I've had Villanova from the
beginning of the tournament and they're
playing who and they are playing
Michigan okay in the fine
I still think Virginia has a chance I
have not given up on the Cavaliers their
defense no they have an injury to
overcome wait did you pick Virginia the
beginning I had Virginia oh that's right
you had the lock that the Virginia was
winning right yeah too soon they're open
against em Sorry Sorry
listen they love me on Twitter yeah they
do we love you to some gradual ations on
your at me thank you so much yeah did
you guys believe him about the team
thing over the individual thing cuz I
didn't believe him didn't that's okay
no you should he said it like he meant
it no that's these guys that's the real
deal I know how hard these guys work
that's the yes and I there's nothing
better than being able to share it I
mean I it's nice to get nominated
individually but you know I got to share
it with 50 people yesterday you know
that's that's great well I will say this
and in the wake of you know you leave an
NBC deal you know someone in the
industry it sort of trying to forge my
own path the moves that you've made
leaving the mothership and creating I
know how hard it was for you to create
this show and the risks of doing that
and these guys believed in you and I
know that it was touch and go for a
while so the fact that you guys are a
reward in that way I hope you went it
was a little well said nominated I hope
I know I'm not nominated for Emmy I
gotta work on that
Mike can I be part of you went to Duke
shuttle policy I've guest hosted I've
been a guest a million times am I not
part of the Emmy Reggie Miller is the
fifth in it okay he coined that he
coined them the den ants that works yes
that works to me said thank you and the
athletic and yes sir and many many many
blessings weddings and bar mitzvahs to
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]